wie fast überall findet auch im
sächsischen meerane unterricht corona
bedingt nur online stadt längst sollten
dafür in den schulen laptops für lehrer
bereit stehen
dafür hatte die bundesregierung schon
vergangenes jahr viel geld
bereitgestellt aber das sächsische
kultusministerium schafft es bis heute
nicht das geld abzurufen der
bürgermeister von meerane ist stocksauer
diese tatsache dass ich ein geschenk
bekomme durch den bund und ich in der
lage bin nachdem das geschenk im
september mitgetragen wurde vergangenen
jahres nicht in der lage bin das dann
zügig umzusetzen damit die lehrerinnen
und lehrer davon profitieren es geht da
nicht um den schulträger sondern es geht
um den schulischen ablauf das verstehe
ich nicht
das ist an schimmel in der tat fuhr im
september 2020 legt der bund fest dass
alle lehrerinnen und lehrer mit dienst
laptops ausgestattet werden sollen 500
millionen euro gibt es dafür aus berlin
knapp 25 millionen bekommt der freistaat
sachsen
doch anstatt das geld abzurufen bastelt
das kultusministerium seit monaten an
einer komplizierten förder verordnung in
den sächsischen schulen kommt deshalb
nichts an ich sage motivisch deutschland
da dauert alles länger und man brauche
erstmal ein stapel papierkram um
irgendwie irgendwas durchzubekommen
es kann nicht sein dass irgendwann in
einigen jahren war ich ja alles versäumt
wird die schüler dumm dastehen weise
keine gescheite ausbildung gekriegt
haben das ist traurig dass das einer
bürokratie scheitert auch die
sächsischen lehrerinnen und lehrer
ärgern sich dass nach einem jahr corona
immer noch diskutiert statt gehandelt
wird
eigentlich hätten meine kolleginnen und
kollegen diese rechner
vor einem dreiviertel jahr gebraucht auf
die lehrerinnen und lehrer hat man viel
zu wenig geachtet
man hat viel zu viel zeit verschlafen im
sächsischen kultusministerium weist man
jede kritik weit von sich schriftlich
heißt es wir hängen nicht hinterher
es musste ja erst einmal der bund mit
allen 16 bundesländern eine abstimmung
zu diesem sofort ausstattungsprogramm
herbeiführen
zudem war die erforderliche förder
verordnung intensiv mit den kommunalen
spitzenverbänden abzustimmen auf diese
abstimmung will bürgermeister
unbereinigten erwarten
er hat jetzt selbst 70 laptops bestellt
für rund 50.000 euro erst mal auf eigene
rechnung ich kann dieses ständige
geheule dass der distanz unterricht
nicht funktioniert nicht mehr hören und
dann haben wir zumindest mal eine
baustelle weg im meeraner sind in
wenigen wochen alle lehrer mit laptops
ausgestattet im rathaus hofft man dass
der freistaat das vorgestreckte geld so
schnell wie möglich zahlt